la question est la suivante est ce que
xiaomi 21 et samsung alors c'est un truc
est vachement intéressant et on se pose
souvent la question on voit la
progression de chiots oui c'est
indéniable en france et progresse
énormément et là je vous parle de la
france mais on reste du monde c'est
énorme les chefs ont très impressionnant
pour autant est-ce que je tiens aussi à
la capacité d'intérêt samsung est ce que
shia oui à la capacité au delà d'intérêt
samsung de passer leader sur le marché
de le rester durablement qu'est ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire de quelle
manière c'est le truc on va regarder
aujourd'hui parce que je veux ça
vachement intéressant son principe on a
envie de se dire c'est vrai qu'à un
raz-de-marée mais est ce que c'est
vraiment un renard c'est la vraie
question
moi j'ai été interpellé par ce tweet
camille xiaomi ont mis cette photo là
cette infographie la plus tôt où on voit
merci shiomi enregistre la plus forte
croissance sur la vente de smartphones
en france sur l'année 2021 et là on vous
met des chiffres donc est ce que je
regarde je vois qu'ils à samsung shiomi
et apple unités vendues et croissance du
match assez énorme effectivement qui
sont à 23 % de parts de marché devant
apple il rattrape fortement samsung et
une croissance de + 45 % et samsung à
une croissance de -31% ok ça c'est ce
que j'aime et il faut organiser les
clients des sources estimations de
canalys sur les ventes de smartphones en
février 2022 alors comme ça un peu moyen
moyen pourquoi parce qu'en fait je vois
effectivement merci moi j'ai une lecture
en entonnoir merci et au revoir qu'ils
ont la plus grosse croissance sur la
vente de smartphones sur l'année 2020
comme ça je viens y croit mais pour moi
les chiffres qu'on a là eh bien on est
dans l'estimation des ventes de 2022
février 2022 donc ça n'a rien à voir
avec la plateforme 300 dawn et 2021
alors y'a un truc qui marche pas vous
voyez alors je celle qui a une forte
croissance une très forte croissance
mais la sec de l'estimatif donc quand on
marque samsung - 31 et sur 1000 plus 45
c'est l'estimation qu'il ya un truc qui
marche pas là sur ok bon ça c'est le
constat on voit bien toute façon il ya
une provocation d'une très forte
progression et il se passe plein de
choses vachement intéressante on va
essayer de décortiquer la stratégie
tuyaux me voir de quelle manière ils s'y
prennent venir enterrer les autres
grignoter des places se faire une place
clairement dans le monde de la vente de
smartphones en rajout parle de
smartphones mais ya pas de des
smartphones et vous allez voir un peu ce
qui se trame derrière on va regarder un
petit peu de quelle manière shiomi
travail pour avoir une ascension
fulgurante pour venir piquer la place de
leader on va d'abord essayer de
comprendre quelle est la stratégie de
l'homme elle se dessine en plusieurs
points regardez la première chose c'est
de venir inonder le marché des
smartphones de tous les côtés est ce que
vous connaissez la gamme de chiottes
c'est juste complètement dingue alors
regardez ça c'est le site de shiomi
france il a été retrouvé donc on voit
effectivement les smartphones et ils ont
fait un truc assez simple où on voit les
gammes la série xiaomi on à la série
reine minott on à la série rémy puis on
a la série beaucoup alors je trouve pas
mal mais moi j'aimais bien leurs anciens
sites au global qui était un peu plus
brouillon mais ce n'est pas ma regarder
sur leur site au global et la même trame
que vous allez sur le site français
avant et là vous arriver et vous vous
dis toi c'est quoi cette boucherie
chevaline il y en a tous les côtés et
c'est exactement ça qui se passe chez
shiomi on va s'arrêter aux smartphones
quels sont tous ces produits alors ghana
qui sont pas forcément sorti en france
d'autres qui sont sortis mais on voit
vraiment l'étendue du bouzin et on se
dit qu'est ce qui se passe ça c'est
effectivement je vous dis une fois de
plus globale en france ils se sont dit
il faut qu'on simplifie tout soit plus
simple et plus claire du coup lorsque
vous arrivez sur le côté smartphones
bien vous vous dites dans la série
chironi alors aujourd'hui moment que je
fais cette vidéo le chiot mais 12 n'a
pas encore été officialisée en tout cas
en france ici donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous allez voir des produits
peut-être moment où vous regardez votre
vidéo qui ont été présentés mais bon
lead exactement la même donc là on
comprend mieux les gammes on voit qu'on
a on se tait pro on va qu'on a on se
tait on bat qu'on arrose light et puis
voilà et c'est assez simple du bon que
y'a que ça ne parlait pas ton
problématique tout ça réuni note c'est
pareil on voit trois ref mais on se dit
c'est cool mais ça c'est faux c'est faux
parce que chez chuo me c'est beaucoup
plus que ça et là sur son site au global
c'est vraiment ça vous avez
effectivement le host et pro le 11 t le
11 light le mit aux ultras le million si
le mit aux light le
mieux valait 2 5g 4g bon voilà qu'il ya
souvent du 4 et 5 6 mai son lit dans la
bascule kadjé 5 g mais ça n'a pas duré
longtemps le million âgées les
références d'avant qui ont toujours
affiché qui était toujours accrochée sur
leur site et donc ça crée de la
confusion et on voit que tellement de
produits que c'est complètement dingue
alors là on est aussitôt globale donc on
va retrouver aussi le mimiques salle
favart quelque chose qu'on ne verra pas
sur le site français ne permet de
comprendre un peu et de voir l'étendue
ensuite vous avez lagane rémy qui est
aussi pareil complètement dingue et demi
note 11 pro et demi note on se protège
et pas 5 g n'a le 11 s on a le 11 à
l'europe on va sur les dix d'avant et
après vous avez les red me remmy naphte
et rémy 9 cnf séries 2009 c'est rémy 9
rémy note 9 provinces encore le la gale
de l'année d'avant donc voyez déjà on
est déjà un peu sous l'eau poko ils ont
un bien petit peu moins bon qu'au m3 il
ya le x3 nfc regagné 20 août il ya le f3
qui est pas mais voyez la gamelle et
elle est juste complètement folle en
fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en
fait shiomi et bien en fait c'est pas
juste chiant oui chez au me font un truc
est ce qu'ils font ils travaillent avec
des sous marques et c'est là où ils sont
très malins et celle là où ça me semble
pas du tout la même stratégie vous avez
effectivement ce qu'on appelait la gamme
me qui s'appellera aujourd'hui la gamme
xiaomi avec ce qu'on appelait l'union
c'est que shiomi 12 qui va arriver donc
ça c'est la gamme de base et vous avez
également des sous marques vous avez
l'art et demi qui est une entité
aujourd'hui qui se détache de shiomi
avec d'un côté leur ennemi note ça c'est
les smartphones en volume et c'est ce
qui se vend le plus et puis vous avez
lagane raid michael et la gamme d'entrée
de gamme avec les smartphones les moins
chers on va en parler un petit peu moins
et puis après ils ont quoi créer une
note soumare qui est elle indépendante
mais en france c'est xiaomi qui la
commercialise et bien c'est poko qui est
soumare gaming de shiao lin a envoyé son
fait un truc qui est vachement
intéressant c'est à dire que ils ont
vraiment cette espèce de côté un peu
tentaculaire alors que samsung ça
fonctionne pas du tout comme ça chez
samsung c'est beaucoup plus simple vous
avez plusieurs gammes vous avez la gamme
galaxy zz ça va être l'innovation avec
d'un côté le fold avec d'un côté le flip
en tout cas aujourd'hui voilà vous avez
ensuite la gamme galaxy s c'est le haut
de gamme photo vidéo là je peux vous le
dire les ont été présentés avec les aces
22 on a le ssc dans le sens metz est
sereine de plus et le s 22 ultra et en
plus pour venir contrecarrer ce que fait
schumi ils ont mis le s 21 et feu on
devrait voir arriver le f 22 et f cette
année donc voyez la gamme mal est
beaucoup plus simple et puis ensuite
vous allez retrouver la gamme à vous
avez le à 0,2 s vous avez le à 12 vous
avez le à 32 vous avez le à 42 vous avez
le à 52 et le à 52 s vous avez le à 72
avec des versions 4g certains qui sont
qu'en cas de diedhou qui sont en 5 g il
ya des produits qui sont plus
disponibles sur le site de samsung
notamment le à 72 on peut plus acheter
il y en a quelques-uns également qu'ils
sont pas trop à pousser et puis ensuite
vous avez la gamme m aujourd'hui on a
deux références ça va être le m 12 et le
m 32 voyez c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose on en a un petit peu moins que ce
qu'on vient retrouver du côté de chez
chuo me voilà je vous ai mis que les
grandes familles parce que si je vous
mettais tous les produits y aurait pas
assez de place sur la feuille donc c'est
vraiment ça qui est intéressant on
travaille pas de la même manière il ya
un autre truc café xiaomi et où ils sont
très malins c'est que dans toutes celles
bien bon voilà segmentation alors il ya
encore une autre gamme dont je vous ai
pas parlé mais parce que pour moi elle
est plus anecdotique c'est la gamme
mimiques ce qui va vraiment être
l'innovation avec notamment smartphone
payable aujourd'hui mais qu'on va pas
venir trouver sur le marché français et
qui je pense globalement est là pour
montrer un peu sont capable de faire
mais pas plus donc qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait et bien ils sont vraiment segmenté
avec de la sous marque ici c'est le haut
de gamme ça c'est le milieu de gamme ici
plus tôt et là c'est d'entrée de gamme
hélas et gaming alors on a à peu près la
même chose chez samsung avec le haut de
gamme le milieu et l'entrée de gamme et
bas de gamme gaming ya pas de gamme
gaming pourquoi est ce que ça ne
souffrez pas une gamme gaming
aujourd'hui à tellement de joueurs ça
paraîtrait logique d'avoir une gamme
samsung galaxy
j'ai j'en sais rien ça paraîtrait
logique et ça ils l'ont pas fait et ça
pour moi c'est pas forcément la bonne
idée donc il faut vraiment comprendre
que je suis on me qu'est ce qu'ils font
ils ont une stratégie pour venir inonder
le marché vous le voyez là il ya
tellement de modèles que quand on
regarde ça c'est dingue et lorsque vous
arrivez dans un magasin vous avez
tellement de référence de chiots me avec
des noms qu'on ne comprend plus eh bien
on se dit bon bah au final celui là oui
quoi comment quatre corps vers le prix
et on regarde la marque et c'est là où
ça me semblait fort aujourd'hui c'est
que samsung reste le leader quand on va
acheter un smartphone on a deux types de
clients ceux qui s'y connaissent hockey
qui vont faire un choix éclairé c'est
probablement au bout d'ailleurs qui fut
mhn qu'il y fait un choix éclairé parce
que vous y connaissez vous intéresser et
puis il ya beaucoup de personnes qui ne
s'y connaissent pas qui ne s'intéressent
pas qu'ils veulent pas regarder des
vidéos pendant des heures et qui vont
dans un magasin connaissent leur budget
et qu'ils vont aller passer une marque
qui les rassure aujourd'hui samsung ça
reste la marque qui rassure pour ceux
qui ne se connaissent pas et c'est la
marque de l'innovation pour tous les
autres mais xiaomi extrêmement fort
parce qu'ils sont passés d'une position
d' outsider je dirais avant 2017 pas
encore 2017 quand ils sont arrivés en
europe une position conquérante et très
forte aujourd'hui et de toute façon est
un truc qu'il faut savoir à qui est
vachement important c'est qu'ici la
bataille elle se fait pas sur les gammes
les plus chers les gars ps la bataille
elle se fait sur quel modèle se fait ici
au niveau des à 50 et quelques a52 a51 à
50 chez samsung sont des smartphones qui
vont faire des énormes volumes et chez
shiomi ça se fait au niveau des ennemis
note rémy ne distribuer notre onze rémy
note 9 sont les smartphones en volume et
c'est là dessus qu'ils vont faire le
maximum de volume même si il montre
l'innovation et le smartphone qui marche
c'est le smartphone de volume mais
schumi ne s'arrête pas là haut niveau sa
stratégie il en une stratégie est
extrêmement forte c'est la stratégie du
fric et ça en prie croyez-moi
recherchiez omis ils sont pas là pour se
marrer qu'est ce qu'ils ont dit depuis
des années nous on vous propose le carif
avec la marge le plus bas on prend le
moins d'argent possible vous proposer
des produits un tarif extrêmement
compétitif et très agressif alors ça se
retrouve effectivement au travers leurs
produits on va essayer de les mettre un
petit peu en perspective pour apprendre
la muse d'un côté on va prendre le s 22
s 21 pouces sont les mêmes tarifs que
nous propose samsung entre 2021 et 2022
si vous regardez un million ce qu'ils
valent et 799 euros 90 à sa sortie
versus de l'autre côté allez on va dire
un f-22 s-21 c'est la même chose on est
à 859 euros on est quand même un peu
moins cher c'est vachement intéressant
de marque samsung a fait un prix très
bas à 859 euros c'est pourquoi pour
venir se positionner par rapport à des
concurrents comme 6 au 8 mais également
par rapport à nos concurrents notamment
tous effet l'habitude killer qui sont
beaucoup plus ils sont beaucoup moins
chers mais s'ils ont bien gardé dans le
plus haut de gamme on va avoir le
million aux ultras le million ultra il
était à 1199 euros 90 il aime bien les
90 et shiomi et là on avait le f-22 ou
s21 ultra c'est la même chose à
1259 euros donc là on va se dire voyez
ils sont effectivement un peu moins cher
mais ça se joue à pas grand chose et
puis pareil si vous voulez regarder du
côté de la gale qui sorti l'année
dernière la gamme xiaot milité avec le
11 t allez on va se mettre le 11 t pro
le concept est pro était à 669 euros 90
versus le s 21 et feu qui vient pour
concurrencer cette gamme qui est à
759 euros qui restera toujours un peu
plus cher et ce sont des taxes sont
aujourd'hui très très proches mais
malgré tout samsung reste un peu plus
cher et dans l'esprit du consommateur
lorsque vous avez quasiment à les 100
euros d'écart ou alors 50 euros d'écart
bas malgré tout ça pèse dans la balance
et si vous regardez la gamme et je vous
dis notamment au niveau des chiots ni
aux regards des uns tout ce qui a eu
l'année dernière vous avez toujours
trouver un chiot mios pour vous et pas
trop cher et c'est là où c'est dingue
c'est à dire que même si vous regardez
un xiaomi 11 light est bien là xiaomi 11
devant donc ça reste rassurant mais
c'est un smartphone qui est pas cher il
est assez long en fête du chien au 1011
mail à l'appellation donc les gammes
sont tellement larges aujourd'hui chez
omis que lorsqu on se dit je vais
acheter un chiot million et demi non
j'ai pas l'argent pour l'ultra mais je
le light en fait que c'était tellement
large que ça n'a strictement plus rien à
voir mais le nom est là donc il ya un
côté marketing aussi vachement bien
bossé en gros si on regarde sur le
marché y aura toujours un chiot me qui
sera moins cher qu'un smartphone de
samsung lorsque vous les mettez en face
à face alors il ya un taux de ce qu'il
faut savoir sur les prix c'est que
lorsqu'on regarde les tarifs
effectivement lorsqu'ils sortent on voit
que xiaomi est moins cher mais après
qu'est ce qui se passe est bien chez
samsung vous avez une baisse de prix qui
se fait assez rapidement sous quelques
mois est donc là ses smartphones
deviennent plus attractifs et rendre
encore plus dans la guerre face à xiaomi
et à tous les autres pour venir gagner
des parts de marché alors chez lui c'est
pas que ça schumi c'est aussi une
stratégie online ils ont vraiment
capitaliser depuis des années sur toutes
les offres qu'ils allaient faire sur
leur site internet pour essayer de
ramener un maximum de personnes et
bientôt sur lequel ils ont été très très
fort mais il ya très longtemps avant
même qu'il soit implanté en europe eh
bien c'est la communauté de fans les
mille fans et les mille fans ils sont
extrêmement fidèle à la marque et ça
c'est un truc qui va ch montfort c'est
qu'ils ont réussi à voir toute une
communauté qui vient qui communiquent
qu'échanger qui est extrêmement fans de
la marque d'ailleurs à tel point qu'ils
ont été copiés par d'autres marques
arrivent avec cette communauté de fans
alors c'est pas la même chose samsung va
pas avoir les galaxies fans mais la
stratégie est relativement différente
mais c'est une force de xiaomi de
s'appuyer sur leurs fans pour ce faire
les évangélistes de la marque en quelque
sorte et puis ils ont une stratégie une
fois de plus on revient sur ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure c'est la
stratégie d'inonder alors qu'ils
inondent avec les produits mais inondé
également la presse les médias les
créateurs parce que tellement de
produits tellement de sorties tout au
long de l'année avec une robe map qui
est juste extrêmement chargé on parle
toujours des chiens ou toujours vous
avez toujours une actu qiaoming si vous
n'avez pas eu il y en a même qui va pas
tarder donc xiaomi est omniprésent
omniprésent avec tous ces produits
toutes ces références dans les magasins
mais également dans les médias et ça
c'est gagnant et bien que samsung
réagissent face à cela et sortent de
plus en plus de produits prennent plus
régulièrement la parole avant d'avouer
une prise de parole en début d'année
pour la gamme s on avait la gamme note
feu la gamme note et on avait certains
smartphones qui sortait mais beaucoup
moins aujourd'hui on a des prises de
parole plus régulière pour occuper le
terrain il faut occuper le terrain qu'il
faut que les consommateurs entendent
parler de vous pour qu'ils pensent à
vous le jour où ils vont faire leurs
achats mais au delà du matériel a acheté
il ya toute l'expérience logiciel est
aujourd'hui samsung est au dessus de
chiens on me voit nuage est probablement
la meilleure expérience android qu'on
puisse se retrouver sur le marché
aujourd'hui alors je dis pas que millau
il sait pas bien j'aime beaucoup
l'espagne ans mireille mais c'est vrai
quoi nous ils sont quand même au dessus
mais ça pour le savoir il faut l'avoir
expérimenté il faut avoir comparé il
faut regarder il faut s'intéresser c'est
pas monsieur et madame tout le monde qui
va le faire alors après il ya un autre
café samsung ya quelques années ils sont
venu clarifier leurs gags est un peu
plus complexe aujourd'hui les choses
sont très simples très clair et on
comprend vraiment ce qui se passe du
côté de chez samsung et puis il ya une
autre notion qui est très fort que c'est
la notion d'écosystème le smartphone ça
sert à quoi ça sert rentrer dans une
mare et après les marques veulent faire
quoi elles veulent vous vendre une
montre elle veut vous vendre des
écouteurs un ordinateur une trottinette
elles veulent vous vendre un
réfrigérateur un le vous vendre un
lave-linge un purificateur d'air dans
les deux cas les deux marques sont très
forts n'ya plus forte de tout cas un
écosystème qui va que plus cohérent et
lemieux travail aujourd'hui parce que
plus mature c'est samsung clairement et
sans levée dans les magasins vous allez
trouver des réfrigérateurs samsung on
parle bien évidemment les téléviseurs
samsung à ce que samsung electronics
fait partie du groupe samsung qui a sa
leçon display qui est une entité à part
qui innovent et qui travaille sur les
dalles samsung sont d'ailleurs
fournisseurs pour beaucoup de marques
sur le marché donc samsung on retrouve
sans smartphone mais pas que et là
dessus ils sont extrêmement forts aux et
à notre poids qui est vachement
important c'est les chiffres on va
regarder un peu ce qui s'est passé au
nom du été vendus on part de 2019
premier trimestre 2010 9 jusqu'au
dernier trimestre 2021 alors regardez
les légendes le noir c'est apple le bleu
c'est samsung et xiaomi est ici en
orange on voit que chez home il ya une
vraie progression était en dessous des
10% et on progresse on progresse on est
au global on n'est pas en france on est
vraiment dans le monde entier là il ya
une vraie progression il est indéniable
quatrième trimestre 2021 c'est apple qui
va vendre le plus dignité pourquoi
passion sorti les iphone et c'est très
logique mais sinon ils sont derrière
samsung et on voit effectivement que au
deuxième trimestre 2021 xiaomi se
rapproche très très près de samsung mais
pour autant après ils diminuent ça ne
saoule reprennent leur position de vin
versus 13% c'est quand même énorme 20
versus 13% mais on voit qui est une très
jolie progression et on le voit depuis
2010 9,1 l'année on est sur trois ans on
commence en 2019 avec 1,21 versus 8 et
on finit avec 1,18 versus 12 donc une
vraie progression c'est indéniable
samsung se maintient ça bouge légèrement
mais il reste toujours à peu près à
l'heure même position mais il faut
savoir que quand on est leader on garde
sa position mais quand on est un
outsider qu'on arrivait qu'on progresse
on peut que gagner grappillé c'est pour
ça qu'on voit des progressions qui sont
extrêmement importantes donc là je ne
monte sur ce diagramme et regardez vous
allez voir là je vous le monde depuis
2009 quatrième trimestre 2009 jusqu'à
2021 autant vous dire que là on va
vraiment une évolution fort tout en bleu
c'est samsung donc là on commence avec
l'arrivée l'émergence du smartphone et
on voit qu'il ya une vraie répartition
alors on voit huawei là toute la partie
noire que vous voyez juste au dessus de
samsung c'est ouais avec les grosses
difficultés qu'ils ont eue et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui en termes de ventes de
smartphones c'est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup plus dures tout ce qui est dit
ici sur le côté c'est apple qui se
maintient de toute façon qui se
maintient et puisque vous voyant rouge
là ici c'est xiaomi et vous voyez que
xiaomi on commence à les voir arriver
tout doucement en 2014 est une vraie
progression à partir de 2017 notamment
quand ils sont arrivés en europe
progression progression et il ya
énormément de par le marché jusqu'au
dernier trimestre 2021 parce que si vous
regardez les chiffres on va quoi samsung
reste à 19 % apple à 23 pourquoi avait
effectivement parce que il ya eu les
iphone de sortie et shlomi à 12 points
donc le truc est vachement vachement
intéressant et après vous montre un
article je trouvais génial qui est sûre
si nette alors ses pareils ans et
l'analyse de marché donc il ya un truc
qui rapidement un vital mais on a des
chiffres sur la france qui sont ici
regardez premier trimestre 2009 1,1 donc
ça nous ramène un en arrière on voit que
ça me saoule à 32% avec une progression
annuelle de 3 % apple reste sensiblement
la même position xiaomi une progression
de 131 % avec 21 pensante par marcher
donc xiaomi à monter très fort c'est
pour ça que les chiffres sont
extrêmement impressionnant parce qu'ils
arrivent de bas il progresse d'année en
année il ya un moment on va y avoir un
point d'équilibré parce qu'ils peuvent
pas continuer à progresser sur des 130 %
tout le temps il va y avoir un point
d'équilibré qui va se trouver où ils
vont venir toujours se draguer flirter
avec samsung mais à la question est ce
que je suis au mythe va enterrer sa
leçon la réponse est non et ce qu'ils
ont la capacité dentaire et samsung la
réponse est non et ce qu'ils ont la
capacité de devenir premier leader du
marché la réponse est oui peut-être pas
tout de suite peut-être dans quelques
années parce qu'il faut continuer à
progresser et que de toute façon samsung
est l'ultra-favori est aujourd'hui le
leader incontesté mais on voit qu'ils
ont une progression qui est tellement
forte que c'est possible qu'il vienne
grappillé cette place de leader il ya
encore un peu de boulot au niveau
software il faut qu'il continue à
convaincre et à se faire connaître des
personnes qui ne s'intéressent pas à
l'univers du smartphone mais sa grâce au
réseau de vente au point de vente au
magasin ils vont finir par le faire est
ce que dans quelques années on va voir
un chiot me leader du smartphone peut
être mais c'est sans compter sur à ce
que va nous proposer samsung est à mon
avis ils sont très loin de se laisser
faire très très loin qu'à moi je me le
sujet passionnant je sais pas vous ce
que vous en pensez vous êtes quel team
samsung ushiro me dit le mans
commentaire si ce concept de vidéo vous
intéresse nous on vient regarder voir un
peu ce qui se passe au niveau des
marques qui progresse qui fait quoi
d'être dites le moi en bas en
commentaire renault fera d'autres et
puis d'ici là n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner et puis moi je vous embrasse
pour décembre où il ya très bientôt
tiens